Speaker 1: So we're going to start today with
our sort of first major results from the 2022
midterms. These are primary results. And the
big picture so far is relatively unremarkable,
but pretty good for Donald Trump in terms of his
so-called track record in endorsing people. Now
we'll talk about a bias to incumbency and all
these different things as we get further in.
But at least for today, let's start with the
few races where we had elections yesterday and
see what takeaways there are in Indiana. There was
the Republican primary in the ninth Congressional
District, not a particularly prominent race.
Aaron Hooton won there relatively easily over
Mike Sodrel. But more interestingly and a lot of
attention paid to this race so far in the Ohio
U.S. Senate Republican primary, J.D. Vance won.
Now it's not JP, it's not J.D. Mendell, as Donald
Trump claimed to endorse at his rally over
the weekend, not even knowing who he endorsed.
It's J.D. Vance. J.D. Vance winning by about seven
points over Josh Mandel. This is the first sort of
signal about Trump's endorsement power. And we
can argue it's not really the perfect example
because there were so many different people
who endorsed J.D. Vance, prominent Republicans
Marjorie Taylor GREENE and Matt Gaetz and many
others. But regardless, this is a situation where
J.D. Vance was, I believe, fourth in the polls
at the point at which Donald Trump endorsed him
and he ultimately won 31 to 24 over Josh Mandel.
So that is one interesting race. Now, remember,
this is the one where Trump didn't even
really seem to know who he endorsed.
Remember this from over the weekend?
Speaker 2: That's what they're waiting
for. They're waiting for one race. You know,
we've endorsed Dr. Oz, we've endorsed JP like
JD Mandel and he's doing great.
Speaker 1: Yeah, we've endorsed JP.
Right. Is that who it was? But this
is important because the MAGA world,
or I'm hearing it now pronounced MAGA by many
people, including Donald Trump. Jr they're jumping
all over this and saying trump's endorsement
reigns supreme. It is the most important thing.
Denounce heard distance from trump at your own
peril. Here is a hopped up don jr last night
shot out of a cannon making this point.
Speaker 3: Number that republicans
because there far too many of you that
forget that and you'd rather cater to
the media, the leftists,
the other weak Republicans
so that you can be loved and invited to the cool
person party in D.C.. No more, folks. The MAGA
movement is alive and well and we are witnessing
it tonight. Congratulations, JD. I know you're
going to make us proud in the US Senate.
Speaker 1: Right. Okay. So there is Don Jr
with a shot across the bow at anybody thinking of
going with the non-Trump candidate, I guess, or
undervaluing the importance of Donald Trump's
endorsement. Now, remember that J.D. Vance at
one point said that he was going back and forth as
to whether Trump is America's Hitler. That's what
J.D. Vance used to say. He then had a change of
heart, I guess, and he groveled a lot. And Donald
Trump ultimately did endorse him. Now, going back
to the results on the Democratic side, Tim Ryan
has what? Now, Tim Ryan's a member of of the House
currently. He's been a guest on this show before.
I think he's a good guy. He's a smart guy.
He's an impassioned speaker. For me, this is an
extraordinarily important race. And of course, it
is now Tim Ryan versus J.D. Vance. I'm supporting
Tim Ryan. We will see if we get debates there. I
would love to cover those debates, but this is a
particularly great race to get involved in. Ryan
easily winning the primary with 73% of the vote
against two two main opponents. And that's good
news now. Continuing with the Trump impact over
in the ninth Congressional District in Ohio. As
of this moment when we are taping today's show,
it has not yet been called. But J.R. Maju Ski is
in the lead now. J.R. Maju Ski is Trump endorsed.
He was also a guest on this program a few weeks
ago. He was a sort of kind of reasonable Trumpist,
although he still says Trump won and that 2020 was
stolen and all of that stuff. But if indeed J.R.
Maju prevails, it will be another win for Donald
Trump's endorsement record to the extent that
it matters on the Democratic side, disappointing
to many. Another attempt by Nina Turner in
the 11th Congressional District. This is the
Democratic primary in Ohio, 11th Congressional
District. Nina Turner losing very badly to
Chantelle Brown. Now, you might remember that
in 2021 there was a special election between these
same candidates, Chantelle Brown and Nina Turner.
And in 2021, Nina Turner lost by 650, 244. There
was the hope among many that this time around,
with Nina Turner having more name recognition,
she would be able to pull this off. She did
not. She actually lost by nearly 30 points and
sort of alluded last night that Nina Turner is
running for president in 2024. So I'm not going
to do my analysis again of Nina Turner's loss.
I did it in 2021, and many of you agreed with
it. Some of you didn't and were angry with me.
But the analysis is the same, an even bigger
loss at this point in time. And at this point,
it doesn't even seem prudent to comment that Nina
Turner for president, a lot a lot of things have
to happen between now and then. But Chantelle
Brown with a very, very strong victory there,
a 13 congressional 13th Congressional District
Republican primary in Ohio. Madison Gilbert
won there, but not by that much in the Ohio
gubernatorial primary. Mike DeWine winning
relatively easily there and some other races that
I don't think are particularly interesting to most
in our audience. There was a Nashville district
attorney Democratic primary. I know of no one in
my audience who was paying attention to that one.
Just not that it doesn't matter. It's just a very,
very local race. So we're keeping an eye on
a number of these races. The Pennsylvania
Senate race is very important that one could
ultimately decide who controls the Senate in
2023, Republicans or Democrats. Tonight at
7:30 p.m. Eastern, the Republicans running
for Pennsylvania Senate will be debating.
That includes Mehmet Oz, Dave McCormick.
And others and others. And we'll be live with
that on YouTube, Twitch and Facebook. So I hope
you will join me there. And many more primaries
coming in May. All of which we will cover.